así gran tristeza recordemos que tabaré
vázquez era muy popular uno de los
líderes principales del frente amplio
fue presidente en el 2005 y en el 2015
por esa fuerza política rompiendo la
hegemonía de los partidos tradicionales
en uruguay e incluso cuando él deja su
primer presidencia en el 2010 tenía una
popularidad del 80 por ciento luego fue
revelado por josé mujica con lo cual el
precio del frente amplio presidio el
país por 15 años
tabaré vázquez luchó fuertemente a nivel
internacional hizo que contra las
tabacaleras internacionales fue el
séptimo país en todo el mundo que
prohibió el uso del cigarrillo el
consumo del cigarrillo en ámbitos
públicos y también todo tipo de
publicidad e incluso las tarjetitas de
cigarros en uruguay no tienen publicidad
y tienen una campaña contra el uso del
tabaco la tabacalera philip morris lo
llevó a una larga batalla
legal que finalmente el ex presidente
tabaré vázquez ganó también durante su
presidencia veto en la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo pero luego se
legalizó en uruguay esto y durante su
presidencia tuvo un roce con sus vecinos
argentina por las papeleras que se
instalaron en el río de la plata' en ese
momento una gran controversia sobre la
contaminación de la misma karina se sabe
que el velatorio será privado a
diferencia de los honores fúnebres que
corresponden a los jefes de estado pero
se prevé en otros homenajes en el país
hasta el momento no como tú mencionabas
más temprano la familia pidió que se
hiciera uso del distanciamiento físico
el justamente no hubo velatorio
simplemente familiares y al ser cada día
ya llegados fueron quienes estuvieron en
esa ceremonia ahora en estos momentos se
prevé que es desde las 13 horas salga un
cortejo fúnebre si desde la intendencia
de montevideo así recordemos también
tabaré vásquez fue el primer intendente
de izquierda del país de la capital y
desde allí se hará el cortejo fúnebre
hacia el cementerio de la teja la
familia y también las autoridades del
frente amplio pidieron que manteniendo
el distanciamiento físico por la
pandemia y la situación actual en
uruguay la gente solamente se acerque a
las aceras pero no concurra al mismo